good afternoon
welcome to our post college
press conference on the opinions of the
european commission
on the membership applications
of ukraine moldova
and georgia i immediately give the floor
to the president of the european
commission
thank you so much
a warm welcome good afternoon
today the college has adopted its
opinions the three opinions on the
membership applications of ukraine
moldova and georgia
we have adopted these opinions after
very carefully assessing the merits
of each of these applications the merits
on the basis as you know of the
copenhagen criteria and the madrid
criterion
you might also know that these are
connect concerning the political
criteria the economic criteria and the
question whether the country the
applicant has the capacity to thrive in
our very competitive internal market
let me start with ukraine
the commission recommends to the council
first that ukraine is given european
perspective
and second that ukraine is given
candidate status
this is of course on the understanding
that the country will carry out a number
of further important reforms
let me
detail out a bit our recommendation
in the view of the commission ukraine
has clearly demonstrated the country's
aspiration
and the country's determination to live
up to european values and standards
ukraine before the war had already
embarked
on its way towards the european union
for eight years now it had already been
gradually moving closer to our union as
you know we have the association
agreement since 2016
and with that ukraine has already
implemented
roughly 70 percent of the eu aqui that
is the rules the standards and the norms
ukraine is taking part
in important eu programs like for
example the horizon program
or the erasmus program
ukraine has a very robust parliamentary
presidential democracy
it has a very well functioning
administration public administration
that has kept and is keeping the country
running during this war we know that
because we work very closely with the
ukrainian administration
we know that the decentralization reform
that the country has adopted is a
success
because we see the performance of the
regions and of the municipalities even
under the stress test of this war now
and the administration's modernization
reform is ongoing
ukraine has a very vibrant and active
civil society this is good
ukraine has an electoral system that has
proven to be fair
and free
as considered by odium
ukraine has an education system that is
well developed we know and admire the
digital skills of this country
and the digital infrastructure that is
in place
and if we look at the economy of course
we have to look at the economy before
the war and there ukraine has shown a
sound a level of deficit of only two
percent
and a public debt below 50
this is good too
so ukraine has already taken
important steps on the path to becoming
a fully functioning market economy
this is important
because of course ukraine has to be
capable of integrating into the eu
single market
you know that we are working on
integrating ukraine deeper into the
single market for example in the
transport sector we where we have the
transport agreement
or we integrate the energy systems
further you might recall that even after
the beginning of the war
the ukraine electric grid has been
coupled to the european unions once all
these steps
are in a very good direction
at the same time we of course know that
further work has to be done
on the rule of law for example
ukraine has come for far
uh it has come far in setting up the
necessary institutions
for the judiciary to function
effectively
and the necessary institutions on the
vetting of prosecutors
the focus should now be on speeding up
the selection of judges of the
constitutional court as well as the
members of the high council of justice
on anti-corruption
ukraine also has come far
in setting up the necessary
anti-corruption bodies
so the focus should now be on the
appointment of the new head of the
anti-corruption prosecutors
and the new director of the
anti-corruption investigation bureau
in other words the anti-corruption
bodies are in place
now they have to become fully
operational
on oligarchs
ukraine has adopted a bold law against
oligarchs the the oligarchization law
and in fact it is the only country of
the eastern partnership that has done so
this is good now here too it is on
implementation we want to see results on
the ground
on fundamental rights
ukraine has achieved to comply with 80
percent of the recommendation of the
venice commission
what remains to be done is the adoption
of the law and national minorities
so in some a lot has been achieved
but of course important work remains
i have discussed all this with president
zelinski and prime minister smihal
when i was in kiev around about 10 days
ago
and
i got a very
telling reply by president zielenski he
said you know
even if we would not apply for european
membership these are all reforms that
are necessary and that are good for the
country and we would have to do them
anyway because it's for ukrainian
democracy
of course we know that not everything
can be achieved as long as the war rages
in the country but many of these issues
can
nevertheless already be
addressed so to conclude conclude on
ukraine
we have one clear message
and that is
yes
ukraine deserves european perspective
ukraine should be welcomed as a
candidate country
this is on the understanding that good
work has been done has been done
but important work also remains to be
done
the entire process is merits based
so it goes by the book
and therefore progress depends entirely
on ukraine it is ukraine
that has it in their hands and what
could be better to shape your own future
turning to moldova
our assessment goes broadly into the
same direction as for ukraine
we therefore also recommend that council
grants moldova
the european perspective and candidate
status
on the understanding that the country
will carry out a number of further
important reforms
in the recent past moldova has taken a
decisive step towards reforms
with a clear mandate from its citizens
it is on a real pro-reform
anti-corruption and european path for
the first time since independence
of course moldova still has a long way
to go its economy and public
administration in particular require
major improvements
but provided that the country's leaders
stay on course
we believe that the country has the
potential to live up to the requirements
on georgia
georgia shares the same aspirations and
potential as ukraine and moldova
its application has strength in
particular
the market orientation of its economy
with a strong private sector
to succeed the country must now come
together politically
to design a clear path towards
structural reform and the european union
a path that concretely sets out the
necessary reforms
rings on board civil society and
benefits from broad political support
this is why we recommend to council to
grant the european perspective
and to come back and assess how georgia
meets the number of conditions before
granting its candidate status
so finally
to conclude
on these three opinions
we did a thorough assessment
and this is laid out in the now public
three opinions
this is a very solid basis of facts and
evidence to move forward
and building on this
basis of evidence is of course a
historic
and a political momentum
and we all know
that ukrainians are ready to die for the
european perspective
we want them
to live with us the european dream
thank you so much for the moment
thank you very much mr president
commissioner you don't have the floor
thank you
just to complement what the president
has just explained to you
as you have seen in the midst of these
very turbulent
times three of our partner countries
have decided to send a very clear
message to us
and to the world
ukraine moldova and georgia
want to join the european union
they have expressed very clearly and
loudly
their own will
which is that they consider the european
union
and membership in the european union
to be the most important
and most reliable tool for their own
peace
stability and prosperity long term
now it is for europe to show
that this is
a reality
so it is obvious that in this new
geopolitical context europe has also
reassessed the importance of its own
unity
and the importance of the enlarging
policy
we have treated these applications very
seriously
but not as business as usual
we have been working very hard
and we have
done our outmost to deliver as fast as
we can
and
respond
to the council which has
asked the commission very quickly after
the applications were received
to come up with
a
an opinion because this is the first
step
of any process
that the commission prepares an opinion
on the applicant countries
we have made a rigorous and robust
assessment you will see
in the documents
that we have been
applying the exact same methodology as
we have been doing in previous cases
and we are relying on the criteria that
are
well established the so-called
copenhagen criteria
supplemented in madrid 1995
which are first of all a political
criteria meaning how the country ensures
democracy the rule of law
protection of human rights and
minorities
the second criteria is the economic
criteria to assess
whether there is a functioning market
economy capable of resisting
competitive pressures within the
european union
and third the so-called aki criteria
meaning the capability
of applying our legislation the eu law
as is
on the ground
on the political criteria i think the
president has already explained
everything to you
so i don't want to repeat that
and i think
my task here would be
to explain to you a bit
this construction
that we put forward meaning
european perspective candidate status
with conditions and conditions to obtain
candidate status for moldova i think it
is very clear
what needs to be done
we need the public administration reform
to go ahead
and to be finished
and we need a public financial
management system
and a reinforcement of the public
procurement system these are fundamental
elements of any functioning
well-functioning public
administration we need moldova also to
deliver on the judiciary
meaning to ensure the independence
integrity efficiency and accountability
and transparency
of the judiciary through the
establishment of asset verification
and effective
democratic oversight
of course we have appointments to be
made
in the supreme council registry and so
on
the third
big area
of delivery would be
the fight against corruption
because we need proactive and efficient
investigations we need a credible tract
record to be established
the fourth is organized crime where we
need increased cooperation with the
regional
with us european union and with our
international partners
to see to it that we have
asset recovery especially after the bank
fraud that we have seen in the country
and we need delivery
on
the priorities set out by the financial
election tax task force also known as
fatf
and finally on fundamental rights we
need
better involvement of the civil society
protection of human rights particularly
when it comes to the vulnerable groups
and the fight against violence against
women
for georgia we are setting out also a
comprehensive
list of priorities on the basis of which
we should be able to
uh deliver
a proposal for candidate status
on democracy
we would like to see the end of a
political polarization that has
characterized the country
and we need the cooperation of all
political parties in the country
and the delivery of the agreement that
was reached with the facilitation of the
european union
this also relates to judicial reform
because that
agreement also covered that
and we need also progress on the fight
against corruption
where the independence of the
anti-corruption agency would have to be
insured
fourth we need to step up the fight
against organized crime we need rigorous
investigations
prosecutions and the credible track
record of him here and finally on
fundamental rights we need
to guarantee the freedom
and professional and pluralistic and
independent media environment for the
journalists in the country so in
conclusion i think today
is
the day when we're making a proposal and
we do hope that next week the council
will follow fully our proposal thank you
thank you very much we will now go to
your questions and give the thought to
ketevan
thank you very much for giving the floor
good morning madam president and mr
commissioner it's a very emotional day
for all of us and
i want to use this chance and
congratulate my colleagues from moldova
and from ukraine
i represent the country and you know
that
majority of georgian people wants to be
with you in this organization and to be
part of european family and
we hope that this day will come
sooner than later uh can you tell us
about time frame uh
we just heard these conditions for
georgia
is there any time frame to for
fulfillment this
conditions
and also what is your main message madam
president for georgian people they are
now very very carefully
uh listening to you what you will tell
them about our european future yes thank
you thank you very much
so first of all
it is a huge step forward for georgia to
get the european perspective this is a
big achievement
and the door is wide open
it is up to georgia now
to take the necessary steps
to move forward to come together
the whole country on the political side
and to show
very clearly that you want to get active
and this also determines of course the
time frame it's up to you
the sooner you deliver
the sooner there's progress
and therefore it is in the hands of
georgia to really speed up and be clear
and move forward through the open door
thank you very much yes please
the middle school national news agency
of ukraine commissioner
madam president as there are a lot of
speculations around that
decision uh i mean could you specify is
that decision related to the fact that
ukraine now is in a war or it is just
because it's have its own
merits to obtain that candidate status
and the second question if i may uh you
have a positive decision both for
ukraine and moldova doesn't mean that
the two countries will be considered in
the same basket like it was for a while
with uh albanian north
macedonia thank you
i think my uh answer on to uh for your
first question answers immediately also
the second question
this whole process that's very important
is merits based
it's done by the books
there have to be and if you look into
the communication they are very deep
have detailed out what needs to be done
and therefore um ukraine has achieved a
lot if you look at the progress in the
last eight years uh the reforms that
have been done the improvements that
have been done the work that has been
done together with us shows that there
has been really progress so merits based
ukraine is now recommended not only to
have the european perspective but also
the candidate status and of course we
all know more work needs to be done
but there too it's detailed out it's
very clear you know exactly what is
necessary and as i said
i think the country itself wants to do
these reforms because it benefits from
these reforms so completely merits based
and each of the three applicants
decides themselves whether they want to
move forward and how fast they want to
move forward
thank you thomas
thanks a lot thomas
um first two questions to the president
um just to clarify when you see when you
say further
um
improvements reforms need to be made
i understand you to mean that they need
to be made before accession negotiations
can be opened up could you please
clarify that or does it mean
need to be made to obtain
a
full candidate status um
and then
the second question there has been a
report from the european court of
auditors last fall
that had a devastating
analysis of what they called grand
corruption in ukraine and in fact they
were
talking not about progress but about the
country moving backwards that referred
mainly to the time frame between 2016
and 2019
so
in your assessment
has
ukraine overcome all these
short falls that had been analyzed in
the report
and has the is the commission able to
measure that because that's the other
point the court made that the commission
wasn't even able to measure progress
and one question if i may
may yes to the very quickly to the
commissioner
um there have been many rumors
that the
questionnaires in ukraine have in fact
more or less been filled out
by eu officials and not by
the government itself could you please
clarify that thanks so
um
the recommendation is clear
the recommendation is european
perspective
and candidate status and we understand
that the countries
will do further reforms before they can
move on and move on depends on how they
perform there's a very clear process in
our methodology
and
the overall methodology has been
reformed i think a year and a half ago
two years ago
and there we got this dynamic into the
methodology for all the countries that
are applicants for european members they
ship
that is if you can move on faster
uh with clusters that are summarized
but you can also fall back so there is a
reversibility in the overall process if
you do not
perform but backslide and this goes for
all the countries that are applying for
eu membership i think this is something
very important and beautiful in the
process itself because it shows that
it's the country itself that has it in
its hand whether they progress rapidly
or whether there is a stagnation or
whether there is a backsliding
on the topic of
corruption
it is a topic it is an issue
we've always been working on it and
indeed
the the people of ukraine elected their
government
uh just because they wanted the fight
against corruption
we have of course seen that over time
and mainly in the last years there was
progress in fighting corruption if you
look for example at inter transparency
international over the next six years
yes ukraine is starting from a low level
but what is important is the trajectory
and the trajectory is positive so they
are gaining ground on finding fight
fighting corruption
that is important you see also that
indeed there was a dip in 2019 but then
they progressed again and you have other
countries that in this
um in in this table are backsliding and
are losing ground on corruption one more
point on corruption what is so important
it's the digitalization of processes
because the the less you have
person to person
contacts but the and the more you have
digitized
the better you can fight corruption and
we have discussed that intensively when
i was in kiev with president zielenski
and uh prime minister mihal prime
minister mihal has very interesting
far-reaching plans what the
digitalization of the country and the
processes are concerned
so
there's awareness of the issue and there
should be and is awareness of the issue
but there's also intensive work to uh
that is being done and this is just a
criterion where you have to improve
question
yes uh on the questionnaires uh all the
questionnaire have been
filled out uh by the countries because
they know best of course we have been
using
uh
data that we have at hand and in that
sense
this
was a new approach applied by the
commission so that we are not asking
replies to questions we already know the
replies to
the second element is yes of course we
have
provided technical support for all three
countries
uh to be uh able to fill it out quickly
and in a non
ambiguous way so that we spare time
uh having no need for additional
questions to be put so it was a common
effort we have helped
these countries but they have been the
ones filling it out
thank you very much i will take a few
questions from
the interaction platform now
and and first we go to tanya
miles
thank you hi tanya milevka from the
macedonian news agency um
i have a question um on north macedonia
obviously um
first of all i would like to know if the
european commission
will make sure that
the proposed negotiating framework
will not be in violation of the iwaki
and the eu values because it seems that
um some of the bulgarian demands are uh
contrary to the eu values and to go back
to ukraine when do you expect ukraine
and moldova to start negotiations and
finally
why didn't you use this
occasion to
propose a candidate status for bosnia
thank you very much
commissioner thank you first of all
i'm not aware of any negotiating
framework
what all i'm aware of is a complete
deadlock
in sofia
which i'm not particularly happy about
since i've been spending every second
tuesday in the country
to no avail it seems that internal
politics
are capable of
majoring the credibility of the european
union
so
at this stage i don't think we can talk
about any negotiating framework
second
when it comes to candidate status to
bosnia and herzegovina bosnia and
herzegovina is running its own accession
process it's a merit-based process as
also the president underlined and it
applies to each and every single
candidate country
bosnia herzegovina has to fulfill 14
priorities that have been laid out in
our opinion
and which was confirmed by the european
council at that time we're still waiting
the country
to deliver on that if we are
to renegotiate uh conditions that have
been clearly
put forward then we would be giving
discounts on enlargement process and
this is not something that we are doing
thank you i'll take another question
from the platform of filiprene
yes good good afternoon a question of
friendship i may
president
you
asked a question about uh
general policy
the technical work
does that also send out a message to
vladimir putin
and then a confirmation just to be short
i've entirely understood
that when it comes to ukraine and
moldova
you are indeed
suggesting
that the candidate status be given to
them immediately and that then the
necessary reforms should start in order
to define the negotiating framework then
start negotiations or on the other hand
should the reforms be started
before official candidate status can be
granted
it's not entirely clear to me thank you
so um the the
um former
is and i will repeat it for you
is the case um so we propose candidate
status
and we know that then we have to work on
reforms that are laid out as i said on
the understanding that these reforms
will be done again the whole accession
process is a dynamic process
that can move forward
stall or backwards in different
a different speed it's up to the country
and here our expectations are very clear
you get the perspective you get the
candidate status but we expect you to do
these uh reforms that are detailed out
and um
the second or the the first question you
asked me
well the whole process
shows how important the respect for the
international law is
the international law that says very
clearly
that every country that the sovereign
has the right to determine to determine
its own future
and to decide where to go and what to do
and here
it is very clear that the european union
actually a peace project
is the destination where the where
ukraine wants to go
and we encourage ukraine
to do the necessary steps we are
impressed
by the fight of the ukraine people for
their independence for their sovereignty
for the integrity of their territory
they are fighting for freedom and this
is one of the universal rights the basis
of our international law that we all
have to respect
thank you yes please
please present yourself
yes hello sorry uh p agreement swedish
david against new yorker since we don't
know how long this war in ukraine will
go on and
i wonder what kind of these
recommendations or
in the process can be done during the
war and what do you think have to wait
until it's a piece yeah i cannot
detail out now every step but an example
um ukraine is already working on the
modernization reform that now has to be
finished for its administration this can
be done during the war and there are
other steps that can be done
there is one point that is partially
difficult for example if you have a
selection process for people to be
appointed to certain offices this might
be difficult because
if these people are either fighting at
the front
or as
refugees for example in european
countries so these are very practical
reasons
but the parliament is functioning the
government is functioning so a lot can
be done and and will be done already and
there's a second point
we should not forget
in the mid and long term we are looking
at the reconstruction of the country
this is a different process you know
that we're working on a platform
to channel all the different global
initiatives to support ukraine
financially for the reconstruction and
there we think it is absolutely the
right moment to say investment and
reforms that's what ukraine wants
so that these reforms also pay into um
the the goal to join the european union
that these reforms are done with the
investments
thank you very much i go back to the
platform uh lawrence norman
but for um thanks a lot for taking the
questions for president vanderlian first
um you you said um that
it's up to the countries themselves
as to the progress they make um but as
we all know from north macedonia and
albania that isn't entirely the case
um
ca is there a world that you could
envisage in which ukraine
and moldova can start their accession
talks before
the eu agrees to move ahead with
accession talks
for north macedonia and albania
and for the commissioner
what assurances can you give us that
your home government
will not play the role
uh with ukraine for the eu
that it has done with nato and that
bulgaria is currently doing with north
macedonia by blocking process progress
or slowing it down
yeah thank you uh for your first
question
very clearly first things first we do a
huge step today with this proposal of
european perspective
and candidate status and we've just laid
out that there's work to be done let's
do this job let's do the work
successfully and then move on to the
next steps
yes well uh if you have a question to
hungary maybe you should ask them
that would be my first advice
second is that
to ensure
that we have all the member states on
board
the best way to do it is to ensure
full credibility and full adherence to
the criteria and this is what we are
doing in this case
now of course
we do hope that
north macedonia and albania will have
its first igc
as we speak
and we don't have to wait uh anymore
for internal political reasons of
bulgaria
and i'm very hopeful that we are talking
about days rather than months or years
thank you very much and the last
question today goes to virginia
this is a question that's been raised
before i just want to make sure that
i've got the answer right
today ukraine has candidate status
and then
the negotiations will continue it will
start at a later stage
and i have understood that you can move
forward or backtrack as well
so negotiations with ukraine will only
start when certain reforms have been
made is that correct i'm sorry the sound
was not very good yeah
so um we proposed to grant
the european perspective and the
candidate status to ukraine and moldova
and then we expect and we've discussed
with the countries that certain reforms
have to be fulfilled
and again it is a dynamic process i
really insist on that
so it's not a rigid process that has
defined timelines
or steps that once done can never be
undone it's a dynamic process so we
expect these reforms to be done if so
then it's merits based then there's a
movement forward
as long as these reforms are not done
there's stagnation
so nothing moves forward and sometimes
if you see we're speaking about other
applicants not these threes
three if you see backsliding you also
see that uh the the accession process is
moving backwards it's in the hands of
the applicants it's merits based of
course we support as much as possible
don't get me wrong
we support a lot financially we support
a lot with technical advice but it's
also the respect for the sovereignty of
a country that they decide at what speed
and in what
form they move forward
thank you so much
maybe i i supplement
on the technicalities because today we
are making the first decision in the
whole accession process
meaning that we propose candidate status
starting accession negotiations is
further down the line today it's not
about that decision
once conditions are met then we will
have to come back
and reflect on it whether we have all
the criteria met to make the next step
which is going to be
the start of accession negotiations but
that is another set of decisions to be
made this is not for today thank you
very much this brings us to the end of
this press conference stay tuned there
will be a technical briefing following
to allow you to ask more detailed
questions on the opinions and on the
enlargement process thank you very much